il ya une autre donnée qui a quand même
tout à fait important à souligner c'est
que depuis dix ans elle a toutes les
études le montrent il y à une
augmentation exponentielle des demandes
de de transition
voilà on n'est pas complètement foutu on
se doute bien que en grande partie il
s'agit d'un coming out qui est enfin
autorisé pour des personnes qui
probablement auparavant ne se seraient
pas autorisés à ça
mais la population a changé il s'avère
que contrairement à auparavant 80 % sont
des adolescentes fille
et la question évidemment fondamental
des réseaux sociaux de l' influence de
la psychopathologie adolescente qui est
en souffrance et ils cherchent une
solution pour pour enfin sortir de cette
souffrance et qui se dit pas peut-être
que ça ce serait bien qu'ils explorent
pourquoi pas mais qu'on leur propose pas
de manière systématique ce qui commence
à être le cas alors aux etats-unis dans
plein d'autres pays mais qui commence à
être coté en france aussi une réponse
qui soit affirmative et qui entraîne
immédiatement les brigands de la puberté
les hormones antagonistes et cetera et
cetera quand j'ai commencé on se rend
compte que finalement dans la plupart
des cas les jeunes vont jusqu'au bout
et c'était pas le cas quand on faisait
des thérapies qu'était qui repoussait un
peu dans le temps en fait c'était même
tout à fait l' inverse et on sait
maintenant qu'il ya aussi des gens qui
des transitions
et qui accuse on pense aux cadeaux
guerra belle en angleterre qui accuse
quand même et qu'il ya eu un procès avec
la tavistock clinique à propos de ce
traitement qu'elle considère qu'elle a
reçu beaucoup trop jeunes qu'on n'a pas
entendu qu'elle était sa vraie
souffrance et que maintenant et bien
voilà elle a été traités avec des
hormones mâles elle elle aimerait être
être à nouveau une femme et elle qu'
elle peut plus tout à fait plus comme
elle aurait voulu elle a plus de
poitrine et donc tout ça pour elle c'est
une grande souffrance et effectivement
on l'a on l'a mis sous zorman à 16 ans
[Musique]